911まん2んおおぉ着実にチャンネル登録させ風でておりますみなさんチャンネル
登録よろしくお願いしますこれじゃあコレだが流行ってから基本的には静岡の家にい
ます肇社長です
3月で3月と言えばそう出会いの季節と別れの季節引っ越したり卒業したり仕事が
始まったに新しい学校に行ったりとかいろんな変化があってなんかこう若干気分が高揚
してあの頭がおかしくなる人が多いんですよ
マジでこれは俺の人生経験庁統計学的に確実的な事実だって僕の静岡がいえもう特定さ
れてるんですよ
ねっとり
ダメだもうすぐ出てくるし
別に調べろって言ってるわけないですけども調べたら出てくるって話なんですけど絶対
が唱えてくださいね来ないで下さいって言っても暗い奴いるんですよ
山順次これマジェスタ高校生とか卒業した高3の人たちとか
車の免許とれるんで行為動画中になってうれしいね編ここでめっちゃいいなぁぜ軽い
境地うちにクレープマジで多いんですよ3月なので私はじめシャツを逆に
開き直りました映画バレてるということは逆に言うとも堂々としてていいんですよと
いうわけで私は常に社長
家の近くに看板作りますみなさん看板の役割考えたことありますか基本的に一般常識的
な看板の役割としてはお店の集客とか何メートル先にお店がありますとか人に来て
ほしいっていうのが看板
の役場れると思いがちなんですけどもそうではないとそうではないです看板というもの
は逆に言うとこないでほしいっていう注意書きの看板年も役立つんじゃないかとは
強まる
はいこないでくださいって言う弱集客通るなっていう看板タッチ理系って書いてある
ようなやつ一緒で裏って書いておけばここだけであると思うんですよ
パン板に入ってる本日より家の近くに選んだぞの家の近くです
こないでくださいという看板を置くことに致しましたちなみに熱いてくださいすべての
教科はとれております大家さんにも確認済みで広告料としてちゃんとお金払って看板
出させていただいておりますので変な人が家に来ないことが私にとっての利益でござい
ます
ネタじゃ年から来るな行くルネっていう触れじゃないんですから本当に来てほしくなく
てお金出して広告として看板だしてるんで来てくれよっていう触れじゃないですから
本当に心から来てほしくなくて看板だしてるんであの声ご時世なんで今度はれだけでも
ユニークるとかほんとやめていただけるとマジで助かります
ベア早速取り付けてみましょう
皆さんあつらに見えますのが僕の歯医者さんの先生です
いい看板ですねもうすごい今早速看板をつける準備をしてもらってます常にどこに
つけるかと言いますとここにスクらしいですめちゃくちゃ大きい
10時の交差点なので結構目に留まりそうですねす4年よろしくお願いします
b
4日
me
eaa
tan
大
すごいすごいすごいこれがカンマー転写者の家
ここからとこ1分家に勝手に来ないでね俺俺俺あれあれあれあれあれあれあれあれあれ
あれ
はい
ああああああ
恥ずかしい恥ずかしいなが本人いるのやばいなぁ
はいというわけで家の後も1分のところに看板作りましたいやこれ普通の人できない
ですよ
住所がバレてるからこそできる最強の手段です本当にこれを見て一人でも多くの人が家
に来ないことを祈っておりますよろしくお願いしますちなみにこの qr コードを
読み込んだら僕のチャンネルに飛べますゲーに来て欲しくないのと宣伝を兼ねたスバル
し看板でございますはいというわけでこの岩盤畑のメンバーとか誰も存在知らずに買っ
てで作りました
多分なんですけど普通の人間は僕が作ると思わないと思うんですよ
めっちゃ撮られるの宣伝効果抜群だ多分ザーッと僕が自分でこんな看板作ると思わない
んですよ
4けど多分畑ノミヌとか見ると誰が作ったんだろうとなると思うのでちょっとみんなを
この岩盤の前通らせでどういう反応するのか見ていきたいと思いますでは
てですねありません
あってのござった
たっけん
何こんなあっはっは
大変これでられたかったやバッハ
困難なにこれ
rar
お一歩家に勝手にこれこれええっ
んだっテラスから夜間パーン
[拍手]
僕らー
いやー俺はこれは今は ha が教えるんですかイヤホン神谷でやってジャック集客
です
なるほどは落ちれの生姜ニップル社が出すすぐでるねー
弱にも堂々とん
色合いどこかで見たことあると思いませ
input やほんとが
ああああああ
ああそうかしかパクっとるだけで皆さん振りではありませ本当に来ても少なくて看板が
せめて
可能
このいで下さいよございます
ああああああ
[音楽]
me
ジェットああ
マジで言ってる件ってああ
マジで言ってる
でマジで言ってる決定